corrupción narcotráfico y migración
Estos son varios de los retos que el
próximo presidente de Guatemala tendrá
que hacer frente desde la salida de la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala
respaldada por la ONU los señalamientos
de corrupción han aumentado
principalmente en las altas esferas
políticas bajo el gobierno del
presidente Alejandro gianmatei se han
destituido varios jueces anticorrupción
y unos 40 funcionarios de la justicia se
han judicializado las medidas adoptadas
recientemente por el congreso el
Ministerio Público y otras autoridades
han obstaculizado la rendición de
cuentas por actos de corrupción y abusos
han atentado contra el estado de derecho
y han debilitado las garantías de
Derechos Humanos incluso Estados Unidos
sancionó a la actual fiscal general de
la nación María Consuelo porras bajo la
acusación de participar en actos
significativos de corrupción actualmente
se encuentra tras las rejas del
expresidente Otto Pérez Molina cumple
una sentencia de 16 años por asociación
ilícita y defraudación aduanera
Guatemala por su posición geográfica es
paso obligado de cargamentos ilegales de
drogas hacia Estados Unidos con el
aumento de esta actividad en los últimos
años Las capturas con fines de
extradición hacia ese país ha descendido
de manera considerable según el
ministerio público en el año 2021 se
detuvieron unas 57 personas 27 en 2022 y
7 reportados hasta el mes de abril de
2023 en un territorio donde el 59% de su
población vive en la pobreza parte de
las iniciativas han quedado solo en el
papel A pesar de este contexto adverso
Washington mantiene relaciones con
Guatemala al estar ubicado en el
Triángulo Norte centroamericano es un
punto emisor y receptor de migrantes
rumbo al norte El 83% de estos citan la
corrupción como uno de los principales
motivos para salir del país el 77% lo
hacen en busca de oportunidades
económicas
Mientras que el 54 y el 48% alegan la
extorsión y el delito respectivamente
debido al alto flujo de personas que
migran hacia Estados Unidos la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris lidera
desde junio de 2022 el proyecto de
inversión corporativa valorado en 3.200
millones de dólares esto con el objetivo
de crear empleos